seguridad y migración fueron los temas
principales del encuentro bilateral
entre Estados Unidos y México Washington
dio especial énfasis a la violencia de
las pandillas en Haití que aumenta los
flujos migratorios desde el país más
pobre de América Latina
vamos a aumentar la capacidad de la
Policía Nacional también vamos a apoyar
un diálogo político con el Primer
Ministro con el grupo de Montana y otras
partes interesadas para tratar de hacer
avanzar Haití hacia las elecciones en el
centro También estuvo el acuerdo
migratorio anunciado el miércoles con el
que Estados Unidos Se ofrece recibirá
24.000 migrantes venezolanos por aire
la base lo que anunciamos ayer es
reducir reducir la cantidad de migración
y regular para que las personas puedan
aprovechar la vía legal
por ello también pactaron retornar de
Estados Unidos a México a quienes se
salten el proceso legal cruzando
irregularmente por tierra y es que la
población venezolana es mayorita en la
frontera tenemos más venezolanos hoy
llegando a México que
personas de Centroamérica
muchos están en México los que nos han
pedido refugios están en México también
les hemos dado visas de trabajo pero la
devolución ya está en marcha como les ha
sucedido a este grupo de venezolanos
devueltos a México tras haber llegado a
Estados Unidos
[Música]
le pedimos
que nos ayude que por favor nos ayude
nada más entrar Eso lo único que
queremos alrededor de 6 millones de
personas han salido en los últimos años
de Venezuela muchos intentando llegar a
Estados Unidos y cerca de 100.000 han
sido detenidos en el último año en la
frontera